[Musique]
l a nouvelle manifestation des usagers
des transports en commun gare du nord
vendredi 22 octobre
m
et
[Applaudissements]
dans une fosse pas commettre
combien de temps je vois toujours la
même poule le même mouvement le même
compressé je voyage toujours assis et je
veux dire debout
pardon est-ce que possible si le
transport en commun moi je pense qu'on
fait ici marche à pied qu'est ce que
vous faites en vigueur du franc juste
mon français
là je mets mes trois conneries mais moi
moi je suis bien je suis avec les
bruyants j'ai des trucs indien
scandaleux d'ailleurs on est serrés
comme des sardines dada c'est ce que des
wagons de voyageurs sont des wagons à
bestiaux bouffonne et le métro le matin
par exemple vous voyez des femmes avec
des gosses on aimait trop on est
absolument bousculer serré elle s'est
obligé d'emmener leurs gosses dans une
crèche par exemple c'est absolument
scandaleux qu'on fasse voyager les gens
dans des conditions pareilles
et pour le prix qu'on paye parce que les
transports en commun ne font
qu'augmenter
il s'améliore absolument pas c'est ce
qu'on a vu je crois qu'ils ont fait
sortir le soir si on n'a pas de mobile
est une voiture d'un on a put aller à
pied un centre pour les gens de banlieue
ses vols tout le vire ont fait des
routes ont fait des routes
automatiquement il ya d'autant plus de
voitures qui circulent c'est donc autant
plus de routes et d'une couche d'autobus
ne roule plus donc il faut dire le mans
un autre on arrête la circulation
automobile dans paris ou tout du moins
en apprennent beaucoup et on fait les
transports gratuits nombreux pour que le
problème se déplacer quoi sans problème
qu'est ce que vous reprochez aux tarifs
actuellement les tarifs évoluent pendant
les world lancé et qu'il n'y a pas
d'amélioration notable c'est scandaleux
finalement on comprend sans cesse il
fallait que le pari que les tarifs
augmentent c'est trop cher à la france
bien sûr les salaires ne suivent pas
l'augmentation que les tarifs
aux épines ou en banlieue nous avons
aussi un handicap c'est que nous avons
que des sociétés privées
alors là je me rappelle les sociétés
privées croyez moi ils augmentent même
plus souvent que le gouvernement le leur
permet comment ça se passe avec les
sociétés privées a bien on vous installe
une cité au bout d'un pays est une
société privée plante un panneau marqué
la stif ou la terreur pour aulnay sous
bois et alors là ils ont nouvel envol
aucune autre ligne de feu venir
s'installer et prendre les clients pour
leur amène quand même sur un plateau
d'argent
la clientèle est là alors nous ce qui
est notre principal problème c'est ça
parce que comme dans nos cités nous
n'avons ni poste ni dispensaire nitoo il
faut payer un franc va pour faire 4 km
aux sociétés privées qui n'augmentent
pas mais elles veulent sans
il ya des gens qui sont finalement
satisfait des transports en commun ici
franchement si elle chutait le courage
de dire qu'il est pour les france port
c'est pas possible
la réalité c'est ça c'est comme pour les
infos je crois que on est tous d'accord
c'est nous qui payons on se rend compte
quand même on pourra nous raconter
n'importe quoi quand il faut sortir le
portefeuille
y'a pas de problème avoué vraiment que
tous ceux qui habitent
bécon-les-bruyères n'ont vraiment pas
vraiment à se plaindre 15 millions de
déplacements quotidiens dans la région
parisienne 3 milliards d'euros par an
dans les transports en commun autant de
temps de transport que de loisirs un
parc automobile qui croît de 8% par an
la situation s'aggrave et pourtant
l'effort de l'état ne cesse d'augmenter
les crédits du type d'implant sont de 50
% supérieurs à ceux du cinquième en dix
ans des kilomètres de routes
d'autoroutes et de voies rapides ont été
construites
on va absorber les deux millions et demi
de voitures particulières et utilitaires
autouroutes une hors antenne de bagnolet
doublement autoroutes du sud où le var
périphériques voie express rive droite
mais les un million huit cent cinquante
mille voitures qui entrent et sortent en
une journée continue de saturer les
routes aux heures de pointe
gênant la situation des autobus jusque
dans ses couloirs réservés
les centaines qui représente 50 km 2
millions de personnes prennent l'autobus
tous les jours et chaque année la
clientèle baisse de 4%
la ratp fait pourtant des efforts 4000
véhicules qui ont moins de 6 ans d'âge
mais la vitesse moyenne diminue aîné de
dix kilomètres heure un peu supérieure à
celle d'un homme du bus un cheval au 19e
siècle
[Musique]
quatre millions de voyageurs prennent le
métro tous les jours 14 ligne dessert
336 station là aussi efforts massifs de
la ratp
trois lignes ont été mises sur pneus et
une ligne à moderniser son matériel
roulant
le prolongement des quais et celui des
trains augmenter de 20% la capacité des
transports vitesse moyenne des trains 25
km 900 voitures nouvelles en dix ans
[Musique]
malgré cela 74% des voitures d'avant
1939 et 13% d'avant 1914 la majorité des
stations ont été rénovés parfumé et
quelques-unes même réfrigéré
trois lions ont été prolongées depuis
motif un beau défi
[Musique]
140 escaliers mécaniques ont été
installés une 250 millions chacun
de trottoirs roulants celui de
montparnasse et elle lit seuls 180 m
[Musique]
pour les habitués de la longue marche
souterraine une dernière amélioration et
départ programmé une pendule
électronique calcule la distance qui
sépare deux trains et permet de réduire
cette distance ainsi que le temps
d'arrêt dans les stations beaucoup
d'efforts pour transporter les quatre
millions de voyageurs quotidiens mais
toujours huit personnes au mètre carré
aux heures de pointe et 1 milliard 400
millions de déficit de la ratp
avant la dernière augmentation des
tarifs
le train de banlieue transporte un
million quatre cent mille voyageurs tous
les jours
là aussi la sncf a beau augmenter les
véhicules de 30% en dix ans électrifiée
et moderniser le matériel et conditions
de confort reste insuffisante et les
trains bondés aux heures de pointe
[Musique]
le réseau express régional ou rer est la
grande nouveauté des transports en
commun décidé en 61 le tronçon
boissy-saint-léger nation 20 km et
rentrer en service en 69
le tronçon défense étoiles 5 km en 70 la
vente des billets est assurée par des
distributeurs automatiques
[Musique]
ici la poinçonneuse a disparu la
perception des titres de transport est
automatique par tour du quai et le
contrôle se fait électroniquement par
des marques que magnétique sur les
billets les services rendus par le rer
sont bien différents de ceux du métro
aux heures de pointe
il transporte jusqu'à 50000 personnes à
l'heure à 60 km de moyenne dans chaque
sens avec des pointes de 100 à l'heure
et
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]
la distance voici saint-léger nation est
couverte en 19 minutes
[Musique]
l'année prochaine le rer iran jusqu'à
saint germain en laye
[Musique]
mais il ne rendra vraiment service que
quand il traverse sera complètement
paris pour les plus optimistes ce sera
fait en 75 sont les autres en 70 des
travaux coûtent cher estimé au départ à
2 milliards le coût final sera de près
de 4 milliards au fonds pense qu'il faut
créer des moyens de transport nouveau
mais que l'on pourrait aussi utiliser
des infrastructures qui existe c'est le
cas de monsieur b g et schmid r2
ingénieurs auteur d'un lit sont les
transports urbains lesquels sont
encombrés mais qu'est ce que c'est que
ce droit
eh bien c'est la voix de la petite
ceinture qui était utilisée jusque dans
les années 30 pour le service des
voyageurs qui a été supprimé la petite
ceinture et vitré l'encombrement des
gare centrale et permettrait aux
voyageurs de ne pas rentrer dans paris à
20 km également inutilisés la grande
ceinture faciliter les liaisons de
banlieue en banlieue problème de plus en
plus préoccupante d'autres projets
ferait gagner du temps la liaison aval
il garde hawks et est le prolongement de
la ligne de saut jusqu'à chatelet effet
obligé et schmieder déplore le temps que
l'on perd pour réaliser ses projets mais
aussi la lenteur avec laquelle on
réalise le rer pour le tronçon central
on devrait être en train de le réaliser
depuis le début du sixième plan puisque
c'est une des opérations dont nous
sommes sûrs qu'elle doit être fait au 6e
plan actuellement au bout de la première
année d'exécution du plan
on est encore en train de l'étudier
aussi bien au châtelet qu'à la gare de
lyon ces études là devraient être
terminés depuis cinq ans coiteux lenteur
le sans doute n'y at il pas de la part
des pouvoirs publics un enthousiasme
inconsidérée à poursuivre ce projet un
certain moment même il ya quelques
années
la tentation avait été très forte
d'arrêter de travaux là où il en était
et de relier aubert a nation par un
système de mini tubes comme on disait
pourquoi ces les pouvoirs publics eux
sont ils le signe en réalité le rer
c'est trop cher non il n'ya pas que là
il n'y a pas que la question de coût il
se préoccupe beaucoup du transport par
automobile je pense que cette année les
mains prépondérant également un autre
élément prépondérant c'est l'influencent
dominant du secteur d'activité de
l'automobile dans les décisions qui sont
prises dans les ministères
cette influence n'est pas directe n'est
pas institutionnaliser elle n'en est pas
moins efficace
de ce fait le poids de l'industrie
automobile sur l'activité économique
donc sur le politique
alors elle ça ne serait pas grave trop
grave s'il y avait une influence pour
contre balancer mais qui donc voulez
vous qu'ils défendent les transports
publics les transporteurs ça leur est
difficile
ils sont d'ailleurs pour la plupart en
déficit
d'autre part il ne faut pas oublier que
ce sont des sociétés
nationale ce qui laisse les moins de
liberté pour défendre devant le
gouvernement
les positions les associations d'usagers
se sont plus ou moins des groupuscules
leurs moyens matériels sont en tout cas
un considérablement considérablement
plus faibles que ceux du pétrole de
l'automobile des pneumatiques et de
toutes les activités qui se rattachent à
l'automobile et l'aéroport
l'aérotrain vous savez que le grief
essentiel qu'on peut lui faire c'est
qu'il n'a pas la capacité de transport
des moyens ferroviaires traditionnelles
et que son coût d'utilisation est tel
que ça n'est pas précisément
d'engins de
desserte d'une population laborieuse
mais [ __ ] quelque chose de luxe pour
des présidents directeurs généraux les
transports publics la route usage d'une
automobile en ville
tout ça est un rapport étroit avec
l'urbanisme ce qu'on veut faire de la
ville la pensée urbaine qu'on veut
mettre en oeuvre on peut pas les séparer
urbanisme voilà le mot clé même si
l'effort de l'état augmentent et la
situation ne s'améliorait pas pour
autant à paris ont détruit la population
active diminue et les emplois de bureaux
augmentent
[Musique]
paris compte deux millions d'emplois
pour un million trois cent mille
personnes actives la banlieue souffre
d'un déséquilibre inverse
chaque jour huit cent cinquante mille
personnes viennent aux mêmes heures de
banlieue vers paris et ce chiffre
augmente chaque année de 25 mille
personnes en rénovant le centre on
oblige des travailleurs a habité de plus
en plus loin à 20 ou 25 kg mais dans des
cités dortoirs sans possibilités
d'emploi et de loisirs l'île de
transformer ce mouvement ne fait que
renforcer les inégalités entre les
usagers on peut dire à l'heure actuelle
que plus les salariés ont des revenus
modestes plus dix habitent loin et leur
temps de transport est long dans 15 ans
quatre habitants sur cinq habiteront la
banlieue si on rapproche pas l'habitat
de l'emploi la situation des transports
ne pourra pas s'améliorer
l'espoir actuellement réside dans les
villes nouvelles responsables de cergy
pontoise une des cinq villes nouvelles
de la région parisienne
monsieur hirsch parce que cergy pontoise
ne risque pas de devenir une nouvelle
ville dortoir et c c'est l'originalité
des villes nouvelles
jusqu'à présent s'est beaucoup occupé du
logement on a construit des centaines de
milliers de logements dans la région
parisienne mais on ne s'est pas occupé
du reste et dans les villes nouvelles
on s'occupe d'abord du reste dans et en
particulier de créer des emplois et même
à cergy on a commencé par un planté d
alice mais voilà la première usine qui
s'est ouvert au mois d'avril dernier qui
occupe 350 personnes et demain 700
personnes et il y a cinq ou six zones
industrielles qui sont en cours de
remplissage actuellement que les gens
qui habitent ici sont les gens qui
travailleront dans leur usine à côté
c'est ça ce qu'on voudrait obtenir mais
là il ya des difficultés
administrative juridique puisque comme
vous le savez pour les pour construire
des logements locatifs il faut faire
appel ou un pour cent des employeurs et
on a fait le calcul que une industrie
s'il vient à cergy il faudrait à peu
près 50 ans pour pouvoir cotiser
suffisamment pour loger du sang
personnel on est donc obligé de faire
appel à des cotisations d'employeurs qui
ne sont pas sérieux alors on cherche à
atténuer sa dans toute la mesure du
possible et en particulier sur les
logements on en a le cinquième qui me
sont réservés et au lieu de les affecter
aux mal logés de paris ce qui ne serait
pas lui rendre service de les faire
venir ici on est réservé en priorité aux
industries qui s'installe sur place
c'est à dire que si vous même vous
prenez pas ce genre de décision ce qui
se produirait c'est que les gens qui
habitent réussi très pas les gens qui
travailleraient dans l'usiné a coûté
seraient pas les mêmes
ce ne serait pas les mêmes et c'est
certainement l'un des très gros problème
pour ajuster et l'emploi au logement
je crois que dès maintenant dès l'année
prochaine et on a fool alternative
valable puisque les gens pourront
trouver sur place
à moins d'un quart d'heure de chez eux
l'emploi un magasin qu'il amorce d'un
grand centre commercial le cinéma des
logements beaucoup plus confortable
quand il ya des prix moins chers que
dans le centre de paris et y gagneront
sur les transports parce que deux heures
par jour
mais paris ne vous rend pas service en
sereine au vent non la rénovation de
paris je ne pense pas que pour le moment
est très opportune puisque cela conduit
à remplacer une catégorie de population
qui était assez équilibré par des
logements pour riches et par des bureaux
en effet pendant le premier semestre 71
on a construit autant de bureaux à paris
que pendant tout années soixante dix le
transfert d'un emploi de paris en
banlieue représente pourtant une
économie de 20 mille francs en matière
d'infrastructures de transport à
laquelle il faut ajouter un gain de
temps d'environ 80 minutes par jour le
mauvais exemple vient d'en haut
ici la préfecture du district installé
trois bâtiments dans le 15e
arrondissement et compagnies d'assurance
ou les banques comme au fond de scène la
compagnie bancaire et même les
ministères près du périphérique
le bâtiment de l'armée de l'air
et que faire quand on sait qu'un
kilomètre de périphériques ou de 50
millions le prix de 800 hlm f4 nous
avons demandé à monsieur chaudière
président du comité consultatif
économique et social quelle est l
autorité dans le domaine des transports
en commun étaient très diluée il ya
d'une part bien sûr la responsabilité de
la ratp c'est évident de la sncf pour
toutes ses lignes de banlieue il y a le
préfet de police il y a le préfet de la
région puisqu'il est président du
syndicat des transports
il y à toutes les compagnies privées de
transport en commun également il y a les
mêmes qui ont réglementé cette
circulation et ses transports chacun
dans leur commune donc c'est il ya les
ingénieurs des positions si en fait si
vous voulez nous avons là toute une
série de personnes d'institutions
d'organismes qui doivent se concerter et
qui devant l'opinion publique doivent se
mettre d'accord pour une politique
cohérente des transports en commun dans
cette région est est ce que toutes les
personnes arrivent à se mettre d'accord
il faudra bien qu'elle s'y met c'est une
question de survie il n'y aura plus de
lits de renault n'y aura pas de levier
économique ni de vie sociale ni de vie
culturelle dans cette région parisienne
si on ne règle pas rapidement
c'est urgent il est encore temps mais
juste le temps de régler ses problèmes
de transports en commun ils deviennent
irritant un tel point que on peut les
poser les indiqué comme vraiment le
problème numéro un de notre région
le problème des transports en commun
comme les problèmes de l'urbanisme comme
le problème de l'aménagement des villes
aménagement du territoire est un acte
politique
il faut un patron dans la région
parisienne responsable des transports en
commun
[Musique]
18 heures gare de l'est image de plus
banal d'une femme qui court après
centrale dans un quart d'heure ou une
heure peut-être elle sera chez elle mais
combien faudra-t-il attendre encore pour
que ces hommes et ces femmes cessent de
perdre des heures dans la fatigue et
l'inconfort des transports en commun
[Musique]